benítez
tras años de retrasos y cerca de 10 mil
millones de dólares en inversión el
telescopio espacial james webb por fin
fue enviado al espacio desde la guayana
francesa la planificación de este
proyecto comenzó a fines de la década de
1980 y la construcción comenzó en 2002
en el proceso unieron fuerzas la nasa la
agencia europea y la canadiense el
observatorio más caro de la historia
espacial ayudará a los científicos a
desvelar algunos misterios del universo
como la formación de las primeras
galaxias
ciertamente estoy muy entusiasmado con
las atmósferas de exoplanetas y en
particular las mediciones de atmósferas
alrededor de estrellas que son lo
suficientemente pequeñas como para tener
una superficie rocosa y temperatura
ambiente y que tal vez puedan albergar
vida el potente gigantesco aparato
complementará el telescopio hubble
puesto en órbita en 1990 precisamente su
enorme tamaño de 20 x 14 metros fue uno
de los principales desafíos sin embargo
los ingenieros lo hicieron plegable para
poder ponerlo dentro de la nave que lo
transportó
el conjunto de espejos mide unos 65
metros de diámetro lo que determina una
superficie recolectora de luz siete
veces mayor a la de jabón lo que se
traduce en una potencia hasta cien veces
superior al telescopio hubble está
optimizado para ver la parte del
universo que nuestros ojos pueden ver
mientras el telescopio james webb está
premiado para ver en la parte infrarroja
del espectro ahora sólo nos queda
esperar que datos encontrar a nuestro
nuevo ojo en el universo